simply good you were skeptical skeptical
you were skeptical yeah and when I ended
the biography I was crying my eyes were
was what stopped almost struggle yes it
was a very father is a taste
lately so the price yes my mother is
Christian but she doesn't practice her
religion and when I became Muslim my
mother told me I don't know I I can I
can believe that it happened because you
are you are grab a cell phone so the
rose
[Music]
as-salam-o-alaikum guys we are in
Valencia and I told you we're going to
be meeting some wonderful people people
who have found their purpose in life who
are living this wonderful beautiful way
of life I found another brother Daniel
now Salah wanted one of luck peace be
with you he said
you accepted Islam two years ago - so
why why did you accept it I was studying
Islam on internment also I met a person
I was talking with me about Islam and
after three months more or less I
decided to to come back so after three
months to become a Muslim Muslim I was I
was a sceptic are you were skeptical
skeptical you were skeptical yes very
skeptical okay yeah but then you did
your homework you start to investigate
look into it last yes I was lucky
because because I became so I became in
the all the people was really with me
okay so that was two years ago
I tell you what they were they were they
were yeah they were anyway no problem so
Danielle so your spam you're from Spain
you were born in Spain yeah that is
amazing okay so someone brought this
message to you and now they shared it
with you and now you looked into it you
investigated it you turned on your brain
right yes most people don't do that
that's the problem you know do you feel
like if more people would do what you
did they just look I mean don't just
there is a beautiful statement by a wise
man one of the greatest forms of
ignorance is to reject something you
know nothing
you understand yes so one of the
greatest forms of ignorant is you're
rejecting something you know nothing
about so many people reject Islam they
know nothing about it but you wanted to
know something about it you investigated
three months so three months you were
looking at it into it huh it was enough
for me for three months
if you focus focus on the study and you
really want to know what this is now
what is the things in three months what
stood out what are some of the things
you were learning that you remember in
your in your investigation of Islam that
really attracted you is how would I read
the biography of our prophet muhammad
alaihi salam and when I ended the
biography I was prayin my eyes were was
what with his wow did you hear that so
that was one of the things reading the
biography of the last and final
messenger sent to mankind I often repeat
he was a messenger like Jesus like Moses
like Abraham like the messengers that
came at the same message God Almighty he
loves us he didn't leave us in the
darkness after he's created us he sent
messengers they all came with the same
message worship the One God don't
worship creation so you said it made
your eyes white wow that's amazing
what else can you share with us okay
[Music]
give us another one okay and when I in
my first time when I was praying in in
the street because it was about Ramadan
and I was trying to do all perfect
weight now so you're praying in the
street now yeah you're right you already
know you don't care yeah we got some
Muslims who are Muslim and there he's
accepting Islam and now some Muslims are
themselves not even praying at all but
you are so full of love for Islam for
your Creator that you're even times for
pray and now you're even wherever we
must pray you don't to miss the time we
pray in the street yeah yes yeah so what
happens there so tell us finish the
story
okay I was with a friend in a party and
it was a awesome time
and we we were able to bridge to create
the to get to the most tomorrow yes time
okay so we decide to do pray on the
inner part I was really afraid because
it was very crowded
yeah with people and I wasn't inside
like like nervous haha and my friend
told me it's okay don't worry
allies with with us yeah yes pray and
forget all the people around us and I
did that and I was really nervous
because in front of us like 10 or 12
meters yeah it was no it was it was it
was people yeah there were there were
people a lot of people looking to us
yeah with child so naturally you kind of
feel kind of little bit shy yeah and I
was more afraid oh yeah so I prayed
yeah and when I finished my my prayin
all day that the children
we're in the in that this place
yes came to know came to us running this
yes let all the children and when they
reach reach us and they they they ask a
question to us are the woodland and yes
we are Muslims and they say Syria and I
was like this was a Allah was listening
to me
yes it is so those people that you were
a little bit shy and they were okay man
this is amazing and it was writing
because it it was like you felt like it
was here nervous and they were most yeah
I guess yeah and then the annual were
one with joy and a Miss pain is not very
common to to see this to see that yeah
this is amazing
so what what else can you tell us give
us one more thing that now for people
who are new I mean is Islam are there a
lot of people from Spain now with the
rich history of Islam when they look
into the roots and the history is it
easy to talk to the Spanish people in
this area you let you live now in
Valencia here yes America yeah how has
it been with your family how how was it
then now what have they been receptive
from it has it been a hard struggle how
do you overcome this yes it was a
struggle struggle yes it was a very
hardest one because my father is a taste
native to the frontiers and my mother is
but she doesn't practice fair inhalation
and when we can Muslim my mother told me
I don't know I can I can believe that it
happened because you are you are Sam you
betray us you betray your family because
we are all Christians and it was really
difficult sad for me very sad
no it's more than self what answer and
write depressing yes depressing because
my mum you know but it's ok now what now
I'm ok my family and they respect me
so it's ok summer several patients
patient so you grew from this you learn
from this yes you didn't see many people
this is a good gem of wisdom that you
didn't give up no no no never never give
up you must go to keep it keep going yes
keep going keep strong suburb be patient
keep going going I'm terrified as they
say yes we do this is a fact it's a fact
if you are confident and you
[Music]
to do something for Allah that we will
help you yes the Creator will be with
you we'll help you don't give us a Lewis
ace yeah if they don't align oh yeah
that's a truth you want to so you went
through the struggles you went through
the hardships come to life in itself I
mean to grow you're gonna have to go
through struggles we all go through them
if you're in Islam you're out but the
beautiful thing is Islam the Creator he
gives us the tools to deal with them
right right so we don't turn to alcohol
we don't need to go to the pub you know
to drink our problems away you got in in
America you have over 30% of people you
know aren't prescription drugs
painkiller many people are on cocaine
memory people are drugs because they
cannot fill this void right there's a
void inside the human heart and people
are turning to all sorts of things but
here we have it the solution is in what
the crater sent is in this way of life
right so you found it I'm so happy that
you shared this story finally closing
what advice is a lot of propaganda
there's a lot of negative things that
people are trying to keep people away
sway people away the tear people away
from the truth of Islam so what advice
do you have for those people who they
they like the message that they're
hearing from you
they like their the idea that goes with
the nature worship the Creator alone not
the creation it's simple to understand
what do you advice do you have but they
have this some of these in stereotypes
in their head
for invisible that is thinking like that
okay this is my vision
yeah I think they should they studied
Islam and Islam and talked with people
who right now out early German talk to
Muslims Muslims Muslims Muslims are not
our region okay
Islam is the religion Muslims are human
beings there that's perfect there now
then all our pick em maybe tomorrow I
can do something matter yeah this is
don't judge the the car by the driver we
say all right and sometimes everybody
[Music]
study Islam or there you go I mean
that's to educate yourself educate
yourself
tell him in Spanish I was a reasonable
yeah what author was a telecom Adam you
know he he brought a book he wrote a
book on the history so the the biography
of Prophet Muhammad yes yes okay the
biography the Prophet Muhammad the
Prophet Muhammad an elder is a tariq
ramadhan that's that was the biographer
okay that's the one okay nice it's an
idea so in Spanish give a message in
Spanish to the Spanish speakers about
something short about Islam when I say
Salaam
so espanol then immediately started us
on us a legacy and a sample valid Islam
you have a motion man you understand I
just have to go Wally look well no you
wanna [ __ ] me on your target on your
noggin see boy that's what L Islam
it doesn't agree with us about Islam
okay Liza Fonda in some level it can end
of the yes I guess to the other CJ oh
yeah we all trying to say mom said all
the specific support complicado ever
seek you know okay I spoke about this
another you know I should have a funky
it's time expected so maybe that service
yeah yeah you don't want it on yours II
your son just cares Messiah also agree
that this death is on your side so
please welcome thank you brother
very nice meeting you here in Valencia
with our brother and thank you very much
for sharing that with you hopefully this
can penetrate this can be a means for
someone to connect with your story and
it can take some of these gems
we're here in Spain Valencia keep tuned
in here in here to the Dean show
subscribe if you haven't already we'll
see you next time peace be with you a
Salam alaikum saying in Spanish how do
you say it peace be with you in Spanish
and I sell most of the rows there you go
peace Salam alaikum